が製作した作品です
タイトルを保存と再現と言います
白犬が台の上に横たわっています
第の中にはエラーフォンプレッサーが入っていてそのコンプレッサーからチューブを
通して空気が送られ
犬の腹部に空気が送られて
若干校お腹が膨らんだり凹んだり上下しているのが見てわかると思います
この作品を見た人は私にこの犬が本物か偽物かはくせいかそうではないか
生きているのか死んでいるのかそれとも眠っているのか私に聞きます
今日は皆さんに私がどうしてこの犬を作ったか
この犬と何を変えたかったのかそして今どういった活動をしているのかお話ししようと
思います
私の実家には10歳になる犬がいました
マルチーズの女の子で名前をりんごと言います家に来る前からリンゴという名前で父の
知り合いから事情があって買えなくなったと連絡が来て
これから家に譲り受けた方でした
彼女は家に来て5年前
5年前のある日へし髄膜脳炎という病気にかかりました
これは母親も母親のこれに進みますねっ
あああああっっっ
s 髄膜脳炎という病気にかかってほぼ寝たきりの状態で暮らすようになりました
食欲があっても自分で食べたり飲んだりすることができないので1日3回母親が
分で餌をあがい与えてスポイトで水を伸ばしてあげる
そういった動物向けの介護を行っていました
病気の発症当時は余命3カ月と言われましたがそれから5年間か服に開いたれ守られ
ながら暮らしていました
私はこのリーンのことが本当に大好きで世界で一番大切でした
林は私にとって世界で一番の友達であり妹であり宝物でした
リオ奇跡的に生かしている現在の状況
[ __ ]の奇跡的に生かしている林の体の仕組みこそが宝石のようで
便の体はその宝石がつく詰まった宝箱のように
燃えたのです
私はりんのことが本当に大好きで大切だったので彼女にどうにかして生きてほしい
死んでほしくないと思っていました
それでもしという抗いようのないものが
私鳥の間に訪れて私はその時本当に
この林の子っていうものをどうにかして乗り越えたい
解決したいそういうように思っていました
そして私は便の今林を聞き的的に生かしている
その状況その林の体の仕組みがどうなってできているのか知るために
りんの体の寸法を正確に計って犬の骨格図
マルチーズの国家服ずや犬の解剖図を参考に
林道すっと設計図を作りましたそれから骨をつくってない4をつくって
って筋肉をつくって皮膚をつくって鈴の音の今の状況を政策によってこの世界に保存し
続けよう通しました
今映っていた骨がこの作品の中に実際に入っているので関節が曲がったりとか
触ると柔らかかったりとかほんのり暖かかったりします
製作過程はなんだかショッキングに見えますが私にとってこの作業はピント私のその
どうしろもないしとい抗いようのないものに対抗する
希望の行程でした
そういった一連の動作がその保存と再現という作品でした
私はこの作品によって二つの自分によって重作自分の作品制作によって重要な要素を
見つけました
それは対象の生物を保存するときに
外見だけではなくて内臓とか骨とか体の内部から製作していくということです
その対象の生物を未来永劫を残すためにその
姿を正確によって再現する複製するということは過去
人類が何回も何回もやってきたことです
特にアーティストがペインターがその対象の人物の肖像画を描いたりと花と彫刻家が石
を彫ってとも一瞬の美しさを
を未来英語限界にも残してきました
だけど私はその
対象の生物を保存するために外見だけを再現しようとは思いませんでした
外見だけではなく内臓とか骨とかそういうものをだんだん作っていって結果的に外見が
現れるということが重要だと思ったのです
なぜなら私は凛の外見だけを作っ
いいと思ったのではなくてこの輪の開花している体の仕組みそのものが本当にかけがえ
のない大事なものだと思ったからです
そして2つめに苦しい悲しい問題を解決するための装置として作品を制作するという
こと
ガットでも重要だと思いました
私はこのフォント再現という作品で
しという
どうしようもないものにアートの特性をもって対抗する
そういうことを行ってきました
さてこの保存と再現という作品を作り終えた後私は
便がいなくなった後の世界について考えるようになりました
みんがいなくなったら私は夢とか希望とか愛とかそういった前向きな気持ちをどうし
たら
失わずに生きていけるだろう
便がなくなったらそういう前向きな気持ちを失うということが明白だったので私はこの
犬を作った後に自分の夢とか希望とか
元宝とかそういった前向きなものを蘇生しなければいけないのではないかと思いました
この2番目の問題を解決するための装置として作品を制作する
の問題が浮き彫りになったわけです
では夢や希望を組成するとはどういうことでしょうか
私はその時 sf やファンタジーの世界に登場する架空の生物について考えるように
なりました
それは便が病気でよはよっていく姿というのが犬ではなくてドラゴンとか妖精とか
ユニコーンとかそういった架空の生物に3
ていたこと特にユニコンは良いにコーンの血を飲むとえいえんの命が得られるという
逸話があり
ユニコンがいればそういったし営農はし苦しみとか
氏によるは彼とかそういった苦しいものを解決できるのではないかというふうに考える
ようになりました
では次にユニコンを組成するということはどういうことでしょうか
ニコンを蘇生しなければいけないということは現在ユニコンは死んだ状況にあると
考えることができますではなぜ
ユニコもは死んだのでしょうか
漏水なのか病気によるものなのか事故なのか自殺なのかそれとも他殺なのか
私はそういうことを考えていくうちに一つの考えが浮かぶようになりました
それはユニコーンを殺したのは私だったのではないかということです
そういう考えに至ったのは林を失ったことによって私の中で夢とか希望とか
前向きな要素が失われたことによってその象徴であるユニコンも自分の中でいない存在
になってしまったというのと
もう一つこれは皆さんにも共通する話かもしれませんがその
にコーンのような架空の生物というのは幼い頃はその存在を信じていました
ユニコンのような架空の生物と人間や動物のような実在する生物のあいだで区別が
なかったのです
しかしこうやって現代社会を生きていくうちまた成長していくうちにその生物は本当は
実在しないのだということを知りました
実在しないと分かった時点でそのユニコーンたちは
自分たちの体の中で
居場所を失ってしまってその居場所を失ったことによって彼らは死んでしまったのでは
ないかと考えるようになりました
私はこのユニ金をどうにかして生き返らせたい
なぜならに金を生き返らせるということは私の中で失った幻想や希望も生き返らせると
いうことにつながるからです
そのために今度はユニコーンの設計図を作り始めました
犬の作品では再現しきれなかった関節とか
犬わーまあ関節を曲がるんですけどその仕組みはヒンジが中に入って曲がるようになっ
ているんですけど今回はニコンの場合はその人体とか軟骨とかそういうものまで政策に
よって再現して渡した
時の体の仕組みをそのまま再現していくそういうことで架空の生物を実害させて
そして生き返らせる気帰らせるっていうのは息を吹き返させるっていう事なんですけど
この犬のように人工呼吸器を取り付けてその空気によって呼吸をさ
ているそういうことを行いたいなと思いました
現在骨とか軟骨の制作を進めていますが
骨とか軟骨をつくってもだんだん抗菌肉が被さって皮膚が被さってその作ったものは
見えなくなってしまいます
またはその展示や行
見えなくなってしまうので段階段階でレブや展示で発表していくんですがその
制作途中の段階というのは解剖途中のような非常にショッキングな光景にこれからなっ
ていくと思います
でも私はそれこそがとても重要なポイントだと思っています
なぜなら夢や希望を語る時に私は綺麗ごとのような絵空事のようなことだけを語って
みせたくはないからです
非常に悲しい苦しいショッキングな現実を知った上で
また希望を信じて制作をしていくということが非常に大事だと思うからです
悲しいくるしショッキングな現実を何とか解決するために作品制作をしていくそういう
ことが私にとって非常に
重要な要素だと思っていますそれを気づかせてくれた林にはとても感謝しています
これからも私はそうやって物語を紡ぐように作品制作を行なっていきたいと思います
ありがとうございました